I've heard that you like a good party
you like to throw a costume party I you
know I had this which terrifies me by
the way also I do not like we're uh I
had the best Bachelorette pad for for a
while
um I had a loft on Worcester because I
went to LA for about four years and
always knew I wanted to come back to New
York my parents stayed in L.A but I I
came back and it didn't occur to me that
I could live anywhere other than where I
had lived as a kid so I was just kind of
recreating that and and bought this Loft
on uh Worcester Street and it was kind
it was just it's open space and it was a
great place to throw costume parties at
a swing
um oh my parents had a swing they had a
swing at a trampoline they had a trapeze
I mean my mom also ran a toddler school
but this was even before she had this I
think they just like they're not circus
people
recreational yeah they're very playful
people I guess so I was
um you know kind of appropriating that
and it was effective now of course we
became you know you and I got married
and we were gonna have kids so we we now
live in a you know a very sensible
family home with it's the total inverse
like it's this kind of long and narrow
townhouse with it's very with many
stairs and stuff but there isn't this
like it's not a you know what happened
it's a dance party venue everything
changes when you have to Baby proof yes
yes the stairs are lethal so we made a
mistake there my wife and I have this
little house in the country that I got
in another lifetime years ago that I've
hung on to and I remember when our first
when our daughter was born Nev
screwing in the the brackets for the
baby gates on an iconic moment what that
was for me in my life and then I
remembered a couple of years ago
noticing they were still there and that
both our kids are kind of grown and
unscrewing them and I got weepy
yeah I'm headed to my grave I mean I got
very Irish dark right no Fade to Black
real that stuff is real the one
consolation is that when I get very old
I know my wife's gonna have to put in
gates for me
to keep me in place yes they will come
back in a slightly different context
um but yeah no I I had a lot of great
parties and I miss them and Easter
sometimes falls on my birthday and my
30th birthday happened to be uh one of
those years and um
Q went as a severed ear there's some he
went to like boarding school and I guess
it was just you know inhaled these
biblical stories I mean you know it was
just like swimming in the water so he
was a severed not a man with a severity
or he was a severed ear it was very
impressive and that's when you knew you
were in love kind of
um yes uh and he convinced me that I
should go as the 30 coins of silver that
Judas was paid to betray Jesus God um
but it was really fun it was my brother
went as the Black Jelly Bean that nobody
wants
[Laughter]
um I don't know it was great there were
a lot of Playboy bunnies you could it
was secular and religious yes but people
are you know once you the great thing
about a costume party in New York too is
that they're stuck there because people
party hop in New York especially in
their 20s and you you once they're there
you know they're they're once you're a
severed ear you're not going in you're
not going anywhere so it the the the
numbers build and uh it starts to come
to a boil and people you know they're
not they're a little
um you know they're in this like they're
a little unhinged you know they do
things they're they're they can
they're not themselves exactly well I
will tell you this just as I only know
this from being a sketch player again
not an actor but when I am when I do put
on a costume for work whenever I've
I do
become that whatever that is I want to
be that and it's such a funny power it
has a childish thing but I was in a
sketch once and we were shooting it
outside and I'm dressed as a policeman
and then I wandered away as the
policeman and I was telling people to
move it along and then suddenly I have
like a 19th century Irish accent
power of
you know um I had to do something
recently I think we're in Norway and
they dressed me up in a ridiculous
Fisherman's costume and I asked for a
hook because and I have a pipe and the
minute you give me a pipe it's bits left
and right and um but it's it's just
childish it's child support but it's
really fun it's the best it's what I do
um professionally yeah so it's what we
do it is a whole other level with you as
is clear
um I can't say it enough uh just I'm
again I'm just going to say it as you're
as your old Uncle who had you on the
show years and years and years ago
um you were you've always been very
funny and classy and polite and then
crazy talented so I'm just very uh
um it's not you know it's not earned but
I'm proud of you oh no that's I am I am
just like I'm like I knew her when she
was a child yeah and people say sit down
old man but uh it is uh it's a thrill to
see you and
um damn it if you haven't seen it's on
Hulu fleischman's in trouble you have to
see it because
um the whole cast is great the story is
great and then uh I think you kill it
and it's not obviously just me everybody
lost their minds with that performance
and that's so good for you oh that well
um I'm uh sweating but uh thank you it's
very hard to receive that level of uh uh
appreciation but I'm grateful for it so
thank you okay well if I can make you
sweat or in any way uncomfortable yeah
um a little pinned here Claire uh such a
joy to have you here and see you again
it was really nice to see you too very
cool thank you out thank you